i see vending machines on our thing and
i i think that a vetting machine
business is probably the most
predictable simple understandable
guaranteed type of business you could do
is that what you're going to yeah so
these uh two folks came to me and they
pitched this idea they're raising money
for it it's a vending machine business
uh for it basically it's mostly female
products so tampons and stuff in uh
bathrooms and oddly enough i had another
guy email me a deck about a vending
machine business and i'm not gonna do
that one but this first one was kind of
intriguing they've got some traction
they're making money it's kind of
intriguing and i started doing some
research and i tweeted out who knows
everything about who's the person he
talked about vending machine it got a
ton of traction for some reason i think
it's a lot of people are interested in
this this guy named quinn miller reached
out to me and i did a call with him this
morning very fascinating he worked and i
just want to bring this up because this
is the exact opposite of what we were
just talking about right but it's oddly
as compelling and as interesting even
though it's the two totally different
uh parts of the world so this guy he's
27 he worked in software sales he quit
about a year ago to start this business
he's got a vending machine business and
he gave me all of his numbers and he
said i could reveal it so he's about 10
months into the thing he's currently
doing fifteen thousand dollars in
monthly revenue and he's doing that
across 27 machines his startup costs
were six hundred dollars five hundred
dollar or four hundred dollars to buy a
machine and two hundred dollars to fix
it and move it to the place where it had
to go by the way this is our weekly blue
collar side hustle this is the perfect
college side hustle yeah so on the 15
000 in revenue 65 is profit so he's
doing around uh 97 9 800 a month in
profit so far total investment into the
biz so far after he already bought his
first machine has been 50 000
time involvement per week relatively
high 20 hours a week because he's
actually delivering all the stuff i
asked him all about i was like how does
this work because the reason i reach out
to this guy was i was like hey there's
this like tampon startup it kind of
looks interesting what's your tampon
vending machine startup
what's your opinion he goes yeah i mean
i obviously don't know anything about
that like too much but basically my
opinion is the world uh he goes america
runs on coke and monster energy drink
and i was like what do you mean he goes
let me let me explain so i put these
vending machines i love that
so let's slow down so so the guy
basically buys vending machines like you
and i are used to just a snack vending
machine nothing nothing innovative there
well he does one
quote innovative thing um he puts uh he
installs a credit card machine on him
for about 250 bucks you can get a credit
card okay so he gets he's a very machine
he says all right people aren't carrying
quarters so i'm going to take cards
he puts them uh he puts them so he buys
each machine you said for
500 bucks the first one was 500 he has
27 machines uh with 50k so whatever that
math is so what's that 2k a machine
roughly yeah okay so he buys a thousand
to 2000 machine he puts it in places
like what office building department
yeah so he cold calls uh lower income
hotels uh motels assisted living places
in in uh low-income apartments so sorry
low-income apartments dash
or comma motels comma
assistant living places okay
and so he goes and he basically says hey
put this here and he there's a revenue
split or he pays rent how does that so
most of these businesses the way that
they work is they give ten percent to
twenty percent to the real estate folk
right uh this guy he goes i actually
because i sold software i'm pretty good
at sales and i do what's called a value
sell and he goes basically i say look
your tenants are are if i just improve
your tenant experience by just a small
percent maybe you're going to make more
money because someone will want to stay
or want to rent it he gives him nothing
he gives him nothing
and so he's got a bunch of machines in
like 10 different locations and he just
cold calls them and then it's so
unsophisticated where does he get his
stuff costco so he buys a can of coke
from costco for 33 cents and he charges
a dollar for it right uh and it's very
simple uh not complicated at all by the
way my grandfather used to have a
vending machine so this was probably the
first business i ever encountered was i
think i was probably five years old and
my parents you know they worked so my
dad would work in an office building and
he needed me to be babysat but then like
you know old people also kind of need
babysitting so my dad went for a
two-for-one he basically
bought or rented out a little like kind
of like a corner store inside like like
a little deli inside of the office
building
and um and then my my grandfather ran it
and we used to go like work to register
at the age of you know seven um and he
was like baby baby he basically he
occupied his grand grandparents and his
kids without having to like do any pay
for any like caretakers in fact it made
a little bit of money and then my
grandfather had this vending machine
that we used to go and do this exact
refill we would go to costco buy the
cokes put it in he would collect a bag
of like change
and then we would like go to the bank
and like exchange the change and i
remember being like what is this he had
one vending machine as his business it
sounds awesome and i asked the guy
by the way this guy's name is quinn
miller i'll give him a shout out quinn
miller i asked him i go how big can this
get he goes look i'm not trying to be
offensive or anything but
the operators of these businesses
typically are pretty hillbilly um and so
they're pretty unsophisticated which
doesn't mean they're dumb they're just
not sophisticated in terms of like
technology or anything like that and
they like there's a low-key easy life he
goes but i met a guy in palm springs who
had about 1600 machines and he was
making anywhere from five to 10 million
in revenue with about half in profit
right and i was like well that's pretty
amazing how else can it get big like
what else is big and he said there's a
company called canteen and i looked it
up i i think it's public uh but they do
like 15 billion in sales of this and
they're the largest vending machine
company in america they operate them
yeah and they do distribution so the
thing is is like what this guy does uh
quinn he
finds he finds his route so he finds a
route so he's like all right if i go
from destination a to b it's a straight
line i'll do everything in between and
so i try to find locations on the way so
one truck can do all of it in an easy
short amount of time and he's like i'm
very specific specific about where i
choose and that's where you make a lot
of money is you can be very efficient
with your time and so basically that's
what he does and he said this company
just does that on a huge scale and
they're ultimately at the end of the day
a logistics company and a bit of a
supply chain company but at this point
quinn told me he was like i rented a
small warehouse now because i'm getting
so much freaking coke he goes the reason
i like doing that and so back to tampons
he goes you have to like look at what
the repeat purchase rate is he goes if i
go to like a lower income area these
folks love coke and love monster to the
point that one guy will drink five cokes
a day i'm getting five dollars from them
you have to ask yourself can you get
that for uh tampons or other products
and he goes in fact a lot of the wedding
guys once they move from coke and
monster energy they're starting to go
with into what's called honesty market
so basically at a we work you know how
they like you swipe your credit card and
you only take one sandwich for eight
dollars yeah he's like that's where the
money is right now
huh
and um
yeah that's so it's almost like there's
whales for the vending machine it's not
like everybody buys one every three days
it's like one guy drinks nine cokes a
day uh or you know four red bulls you
know a week and that's where you make
your money is on the like 10 of the of
the residents who buy like 90 of the
goods or something like that probably
yeah this guy was interesting man he's
only 27. he's the lives in san diego
worked in tech sales he told me that uh
he goes like basically i'm a pr he goes
i'm pretty i was pretty good at selling
software um i'm not the best but i'm
pretty good and this industry that i
went into they're just kind of
not that great at that many stuff and i
could outsell relatively easily i could
kind of outwork relatively easily and so
anyway fascinating story
[Music]
you